[Música]
pasamos ahora a nuestro primer invitado
del día porque la semana pasada Apple
presentó las visión Pro un dispositivo
de realidad aumentada que se empezará a
comercializar el próximo año primero en
Estados Unidos por 3.500 dólares el
anuncio de la compañía de silicon Valley
ha generado muchos comentarios y
expectativas Pero cuál es la novedad que
ofrecen estas gafas respecto a otras
tecnologías presentes ya en el Mercado o
qué tan cerca está la realidad aumentada
de formar parte de nuestro día a día
pues lo vamos a conversar con Pedro
aznar director de aposfera en webber y
España a Paul y Tec podcastster Pedro se
habla de estas gafas de Apple como un
instrumento de realidad mixta Qué
significa este concepto es lo mismo que
la realidad aumentada
parece lo mismo pero no lo es realmente
la realidad mixta lo que hace es ofrecer
lo mejor de dos mundos lo mejor de la
incorporar objetos de que no existen
objetos virtuales dentro de nuestra
realidad y también convertirla en una
especie de realidad virtual completa que
es precisamente lo que hacen las visión
Pro no pasando un lado a otro la
realidad aumentada simplemente captura
mediante cámaras la realidad y sobrepone
sobre ella objetos que no existen bueno
Y esta nueva tecnología Más allá de lo
que ya nos has comentado En qué se
diferencian de otras tecnologías
desarrolladas por otras marcas
bueno la tecnología existía antes lo que
ha hecho Apple es ponerle como un
combinado de lo mejor que se puede hacer
en cada campo y sobre todo mejorando la
precisión que tiene estas lentes y estas
y estas de estos dispositivos con muchos
sensores muchas cámaras que sean capaces
de capturar con una cosa muy importante
que tienen que tener estas gafas es que
tienen que tener latencia prácticamente
nula es decir que cuando nosotros nos
movamos con las gafas o veamos el mundo
real a través de ellas tiene tenemos que
percibirlo como real no para no tener
sensaciones de mareo ni problemas la
diferencia con las otras marcas es que
las otras marcas lo que ofrecen es una
experiencia virtual prácticamente
completa en videojuegos en primera
persona o una realidad aumentada como
comentábamos antes que bueno se limita
muy pocos usos a perder es mucho más
ambiciosa y lo que lo que nos ofrece lo
que quiere ofrecer en el futuro es una
forma de comunicación y una forma sobre
todo de computación espacial es muy
importante que Apple en la propia
conferencia de desarrolladores haya
dicho no haya dicho ni una sola vez la
palabra realidad virtual ni metaverso y
lo que se refieren ellos es que es una
nueva era de computación espacial es
decir utilizar todo nuestro espacio
físico para para como Lienzo virtual y
digital a todas las aplicaciones y usos
que podamos hacer hoy en día con un
móvil o con un ordenador Claro entiendo
entonces que lo que se intentará llegar
en un futuro es que a que no haya una
distinción entre esta realidad virtual y
la realidad material a la que estamos
acostumbrados hasta el momento Llegará
el momento en que eso sea realmente
posible
Llegará el momento no es a medio plazo
yo creo que va a ser muy a largo plazo
sobre todo cuando los dispositivos como
estamos viendo la hora como son las
visión Pro dejen Pues de tener esta
envergadura de a pesar de que la
tecnología que tiene Apple ha hecho ha
minimizado muchísimo el concepto de
dispositivo que teníamos de este tipo
pero hasta que no consigamos tener unas
unas gafas normales o incluso unas
lentillas para ser totalmente de ciencia
ficción no conseguiremos un poco Esa esa
preguntarnos si estamos viendo la
realidad real o una realidad ampliada o
mixta de ese tipo pero el camino un poco
es eso a mezclar nuestro mundo virtual y
no estar limitados a una pantalla física
delante de nosotros sino poder utilizar
todo nuestro espacio y interactuar con
él de forma muy natural como hacemos con
cualquier elemento real Claro pero de
momento el precio de entrada esos 3.500
dólares en Estados Unidos parecen una
barrera muy grande para que esta
tecnología pues
sea común entre entre la mayoría de las
personas esto puede frenar también El
Avance de la tecnología a corto o medio
plazo yo creo que precisamente al
contrario lo que ha hecho Apple es no
cortarse cuando hablaba de tecnologías y
de todo lo que tenían que ofrecer estas
gafas para no ofrecer una experiencia a
medias o una experiencia barata que ya
tienen otras marcas y hay otras marcas
que lo hacen lo que ha hecho a la peli
escoger toda la tecnología elevarla al
máximo exponente y crear un concepto y
Un diseño que no está disponible ahora
mismo ninguna en ningún competidor y
toda la gente que ya lo ha probado lo
dice Esto es algo que no se pensaba
incluso que podría ser posible con la
tecnología de hoy en día es una barra de
entrada un poco cara pero recordemos que
cuando hay una tecnología disruptiva el
precio de entrada de salida al mercado
siempre suele ser caro por ejemplo el
primer macintosh que en su momento valía
666 dólares a día de hoy costaría
precisamente unos 3.500 dólares teniendo
en cuenta la inflación y el cambio
actual con lo que bueno es una
tecnología que ofrece muchas más cosas
que de lo que la competencia ofrece
ahora mismo pero desde luego para
ofrecerlo de plataforma pues tiene que
contar con tecnología de último nivel y
eso no es barato claro desde luego hay
mucho dinero mucho tiempo invertido por
la compañía siempre como usted bien dice
todas estas tecnologías son caras quería
referirme a otra de las cosas que está
mencionando Y es que no quiere llegar a
una tecnología a medias hemos visto
también en los últimos años este
lanzamiento del metaverso que parece que
no se termina de extender entre la
población No termina de tener éxito era
el metaverso una experiencia a medias o
qué ha faltado para que haya triunfado
lo has definido muy bien muchos de los
que estamos en el mundo de la tecnología
vimos el metaverso como una oportunidad
en su momento pero también como una
experiencia incompleta porque lo que
quiero ofrecer el metaverso al final es
un lugar no ofrecer solo la posibilidad
de interactuar con nuestros elementos
virtuales o aplicaciones virtuales
también ofrecer un digamos un espacio
virtual donde poder trabajar con ellas y
que sea común a todos no nos sirve nada
que cada uno tenga su propio metaverso
cuando no interactuar entre ellos yo
creo que aquí Mark Zuckerberg e equivocó
un poco este concepto porque al final no
ha conseguido dar reforma o ha
conseguido darle forma de forma muy
rudimentaria no hay más que ver la
diferencia de calidad entre las las el
metaverso que proponía Zuckerberg y lo
que Apple pudo ofrecer con las visión
pro es mucho más real trabajar con la
realidad y trabajar con cosas que ya
estamos acostumbrados y luego sobre todo
una cosa que Apple aquí ha contado mucho
y es la interacción el nivel de
expresividad que tienen estas gafas
cuando estamos utilizando las y viene
alguien y puede ver los ojos podemos
verlo él a la persona que viene yo creo
que es muy importante y el metaverso no
ha conseguido cuadrar y por eso había
tanta confusión mucha gente confundía
metaverso simplemente con realidad
virtual Y eso quiere decir que el
conflicto no estaba claro o no era no
era el adecuado pues Pedro aznar hemos
aprendido mucho contigo en este rato
Charlando Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en France 24 yo a nuestros
espectadores les quiero invitar a que
sigan porque hacemos una breve pausa y
ya volvemos con directo a América
[Música]